Salut, moi c'est Guillaume Hachez. Bienvenue dans Septante Minutes Avec. Aujourd'hui, je passe septante minutes avec Pierre-François Lovens.
P.F. Lovens, c'est journaliste économique à La Libre Belgique, c'est le monsieur start-up de La Libre et il est aussi ancien rédacteur en chef adjoint.
Je me suis posé une heure avec lui pour discuter des évolutions de la presse ces vingt dernières années avec l'arrivée d'Internet et leurs déboires contre Google News en 2005.
Let's go ! Et bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour un nouvel épisode. On est ici aujourd'hui avec Pierre-François Lovens. Pierre-François, bonjour.
Bonjour.
Est-ce que tu peux te présenter pour ceux qui ne te connaissent pas ?
Alors voilà, donc on se trouve à La Libre Belgique. C'est la rédaction dans laquelle je travaille depuis 1998. Donc ça fait un bon bout de temps.
À la base, je suis journaliste économique. J'ai commencé au journal L'Écho, où j'ai travaillé pendant six ans.
Et puis je suis arrivé à La Libre, où j'ai traité différents sujets, matières.
D'abord, plutôt dans le domaine de la politique économique, donc tous les sujets politique fiscale, politique budgétaire, politique économique au sens large.
Et puis j'ai été amené à prendre des responsabilités au sein de la rédaction de La Libre, chef de service, rédacteur en chef adjoint.
Et pour parler maintenant de la situation actuelle, depuis maintenant environ trois ans, je suis revenu à mes premières amours qui est le journalisme économique et sur les matières dont on va parler qui sont l'innovation, l'entrepreneuriat,
surtout dans le domaine numérique, digital.
Je suis aussi en charge du secteur des télécoms. Voilà, donc je fais partie du service économique de La Libre où on est une petite dizaine de journalistes et voilà, chacun-
Et donc, tu es en fait monsieur start-up à La Libre Belgique. C'est comme ça qu'on se connaît en fait.
Tout à fait, oui. Alors, c'est vrai que je le suis devenu un peu par la force des choses. C'était pas vraiment calculé parce que quand, il y a trois ans, j'ai repris un peu
l'écriture et le travail journalistique, je me suis un peu posé la question de savoir : tiens, aujourd'hui, dans l'économie telle qu'elle est, telle qu'elle évolue, quels sont un peu les sujets sur lesquels je pourrais
à la fois, moi, investir parce que ça m'intéresse et sortir, c'est vrai, de secteurs un peu plus traditionnels.
Et c'est vrai qu'à ce moment-là, et ça, tu le sais aussi bien que moi, on parle beaucoup dans la presse spécialisée et tout doucement dans la presse généraliste aussi des start-up, dans le cadre de la révolution numérique.
Et je me suis dit : tiens, ça vaudrait peut-être la peine de me pencher un peu là-dessus. Et j'ai commencé à traiter des sujets start-up, innovation, mais sans vraiment savoir où ça allait m'amener.
Et c'est vrai que trois ans plus tard, ben j'y suis toujours, je m'amuse beaucoup, il y a beaucoup de sujets, beaucoup de matières.
Et donc c'est vrai que vis-à-vis de l'extérieur, ça m'a donné un peu l'étiquette du monsieur start-up de La Libre comme il y en a à Trends Tendance, à L'Écho...
On va revenir sur les start-up dans un instant, mais avant ça, tu disais donc que tu es journaliste économique pour La Libre Belgique depuis dix-neuf ans, donc ancien rédacteur en chef adjoint, c'est ça ?
Tout à fait, oui.
Donc ce qui est déjà intéressant dans ce postulat, je trouve, c'est que ça veut dire que tu as connu l'arrivée, le changement, la révolution du Web dans le journalisme.
Tout à fait. Non, c'est bien que tu mettes le doigt là-dessus parce que, donc en 92, quand je sors de mes études— pour la petite histoire, j'ai fait des études d'économie.
Et ce qui m'a beaucoup servi, mais j'ai fait des études d'économie sachant que je voulais faire du journalisme. Et à l'époque, mes parents d'abord, mais aussi mon entourage me disaient : « Ouh là, le journalisme...
» On disait déjà que c'était un secteur bouché, donc essaye de faire d'abord des études sérieuses, entre guillemets. Et donc, j'ai opté pour l'économie comme j'aurais pu opter pour le droit ou d'autres études.
Donc, je me suis lancé dans l'économie, mais toujours avec l'idée : je veux travailler dans un journal. Et j'étais plutôt attiré par la presse écrite.
Et c'est comme ça que ça a commencé. Mais c'est vrai que quand j'arrive en 92 dans le métier, j'arrive dans une rédaction qui est une rédaction encore à l'ancienne, papier.
Alors, il y a plus les rotatives avec les caractères... pour imprimer. Donc, on est déjà quand même dans une impression-
Vous aviez des ordinateurs.
Voilà, on avait des ordinateurs, on envoyait des fichiers à l'imprimerie, etc. Donc, il y avait déjà une évolution, mais par contre, Internet n'est pas encore là.
Et par exemple, tout ce qui est agence de presse, donc qui est une des sources d'information-
Belga, AFP, etc.
Exactement. Ça arrive sur des téléscripteurs, donc sur du papier. Et donc, il y a des personnes qui, au sein de la rédaction, s'occupent à trier, à découper les dépêches, au sens vraiment-
Et aujourd'hui, ça se fait par Twitter.
Oui, par Twitter, mais il y a eu quand même une étape intermédiaire-
C'est ça
...sur ordinateur d'abord.
Ouais, ouais, ouais.
Et donc c'est vrai que j'ai connu la révolution Internet dans les rédactions, fin des années 90, début 2000. Et puis voilà, l'accélération aussi avec l'arrivée des réseaux sociaux par après.
Et aujourd'hui, c'est vrai que quand je dis : « Je travaille à La Libre Belgique », c'est vrai qu'on associe encore La Libre Belgique à un média écrit, un quotidien écrit.
Un papier, ouais.
En fait, je suis par la force des choses et tous mes collègues, c'est pareil, on est devenu des journalistes multimédias parce que-
Ah ouais
...on est aussi bien dans l'écrit que dans la voix, que dans l'image. Or,
on n'a pas forcément été formés par ça, mais c'est vrai qu'on a dû se former sur le tas pour être capable de temps à autre, je le dis pas qu'on le fait systématiquement,
mais quand on part en reportage, on nous demande de faire des photos, on nous demande de prendre du son, éventuellement des petites vidéos, parce qu'aujourd'hui, voilà, de plus en plus de nos lecteurs sont des internautes.
Mmh. Justement, je voulais te demander, mais quelle est l'importance du Web pour La Libre aujourd'hui ? Puisque justement, on sait que vous donnez vingt-quatre heures d'avance, vingt-quatre heures d'exclusivité au papier par rapport au Web.
On sait que beaucoup d'articles sur votre site Web ne sont pas accessibles si on n'est pas abonné.
Il y a deux choses dans la question. C'est vrai que les vingt-quatre heures, elle est-- en fait, elle est déjà en train de...
C'est vrai qu'elle a existé. Ça veut dire qu'on voulait donner une priorité à nos abonnés papier, parce que sur le plan économique, du modèle économique, c'est vrai que le papier reste quand même, même s'il est en déclin-
Au niveau du revenu
Exactement. Dans le chiffre d'affaires, l'abonnement papier reste quand même la part majoritaire. Ceci étant, l'évolution fait qu'on a de moins en moins d'abonnés papier et que
on a, par contre, de nouveaux lecteurs ou des lecteurs qui passent du papier au Web,
ou bien seulement des lecteurs Web et qui, eux, bon, soit on les fait pas payer et on compte sur la publicité pour nous financer.
Malheureusement, ça fonctionne pas comme ça. Les recettes publicitaires sont inférieures sur le Web, en tout cas pour La Libre Belgique que sur le papier.
Et donc c'est vrai qu'on passe dans un modèle payant sur le Web. Y a encore des parties gratuites, mais y a de plus en plus de payant.
Et donc tout ça évolue. Y a pas de règles fixes et chaque entreprise de presse cherche un peu son modèle. Mais aujourd'hui, effectivement,
sur une audience de, je dirais, de-- en 250 000 lecteurs, ça, c'est quand on additionne l'audience des lecteurs papier plus les lecteurs des applications, Web, tablettes, smartphones, etc.
On est, à ma connaissance-- voilà, l'audience papier reste majoritaire, mais elle décroît. Donc-
D'accord
...aujourd'hui, la part Web ne fait qu'augmenter, elle n'est pas encore dominante. Et alors, dans cette part Web, la part payante, elle augmente aussi, mais pas à pas, je dirais.
Aujourd'hui, on a un peu plus de 7 000 abonnés payants numériques, des purs numériques.
D'accord, oui.
Et on a 30 000 plus ou moins abonnés papier. Et alors, il faut ajouter à ça ceux qui achètent La Libre en librairie, mais ça reste, qui est, elle-
C'est minoritaire, oui. Hm, d'accord
Donc voilà, ça donne un peu les ordres de grandeur. Donc le Web n'est pas encore dominant, mais il croît, ce qui est une bonne nouvelle.
C'est une bonne nouvelle, mais en même temps, tu as l'air de dire que vous ne gagnez pas tellement d'argent grâce-
Pas encore
...au Web et que le papier, c'est ce qui vous drive-
Tout à fait. Oui, mais c'est pour ça, c'est toute la difficulté-
...et en même temps, le papier est faible, c'est plutôt inquiétant, ce que tu me dis, en fait.
C'est vrai. C'est vrai. D'ailleurs, ça peut paraître, si pas contradictoire, en tout cas un peu flou. Et ça l'est, parce qu'on est vraiment dans cette période de transition, transformation digitale.
On passe d'un média papier à un média Web, mais en ayant une cohabitation des deux pour l'instant. Mais comme tu sais, faire un média Web ou faire un média papier, les coûts sont différents.
Et quand tu fais un journal papier, tu as une imprimerie, tu dois te fournir en papier, en encre, tu as de la distribution, de la logistique, ça coûte très cher.
Et donc, c'est vrai que l'économie, là, est compliquée parce que les volumes papier diminuent, mais tu as quand même des coûts fixes importants.
Tandis que fabriquer un journal Web, ben ça coûte beaucoup moins cher, mais ça rapporte moins. Et donc voilà, aujourd'hui, honnêtement, c'est compliqué.
Vous êtes dans le flou, ouais.
On est-- ouais, j'espère que les services financiers commerciaux de La Libre sont beaucoup moins dans le flou que moi. Mais en tant que journaliste, c'est vrai que je n'ai pas forcément toujours une vision claire.
Est-ce que c'est spécifique à La Libre Belgique ?
Non, non, non.
Puisque tu m'expliquais que le public de La Libre Belgique était peut-être un peu plus âgé que les autres.
Oui, tout à fait.
Est-ce que tout ça est lié ou est-ce que c'est-
C'est pas spécifique à La Libre. C'est-à-dire, cette transformation que j'expliquais-
Hm hm
...elle est vécue par tous les médias du monde. Et, si on se limite à la Belgique, c'est la même chose-
D'accord
...au Morgen que, qu'au Soir ou à La Libre. Maintenant, le point de départ n'est pas toujours le même.
Un journal avec une plus grosse audience, un plus gros tirage va effectivement avoir peut-être plus de facilité à amortir le choc de la révolution numérique par rapport à un journal qui a des volumes plus restreints.
Tu as listé, tu as passé en revue les changements pour La Libre Belgique. Si tu devais passer en revue les changements de ces 20 dernières années pour le journalisme.
Oui, oui.
L'impact que le World Wide Web a eu sur le journalisme. Qu'est-ce qui a changé finalement ? Parce que certains disent que le journalisme est en danger aujourd'hui.
Est-ce que ça te paraît juste ?
Si on essaie de prendre un peu de recul, et notamment par rapport à ce qu'on a pu connaître ces derniers mois et qui est quand même quelque chose de
à la fois d'important, mais on a peut-être pas assez le recul par rapport aux fake news.
On sent bien que
les fake news sont une tendance à la fois nouvelle et de fond, mais,
j'attends un peu de voir comment les choses-- c'est un peu difficile de se prononcer parce qu'on voit aussi que les réseaux sociaux eux-mêmes sont en train d'adapter leurs modèles, leurs algorithmes.
Et donc, dans quelle mesure ce qui s'est passé, bon, les cas les plus classiques, c'est avec le Brexit et les élections de Trump, dans quelle mesure ce seront des incidents graves, mais qui seront peut-être rapidement rectifiés ?
J'en sais rien. Mais pour répondre à ta question, moi, j'essaie de me convaincre que la technologie n'a pas fondamentalement transformé la manière dont je veux pratiquer mon métier de journaliste.
Les règles, les fondamentaux, je dirais, restent-
Les fondamentaux. Mais si on prend un contre-exemple de ça, on pourrait dire, par exemple, que les questions de référencement, les questions de clics, pour la presse sur le Web vont faire, par exemple, qu'on va plutôt titrer sur
le chien qui est mort écrasé par une voiture que sur les news économiques.
C'est vrai. Alors, une façon de botter en touche, c'est de se dire : « C'est pas trop mon métier ».
Aujourd'hui, c'est vrai que tu as,
tu as-- les métiers ont évolué. Le métier du journaliste, il est à réinventer, il s'est transformé aussi, mais tu as de nouveaux intervenants qui sont apparus dans les rédactions, notamment,
via la gestion des sites, des réseaux sociaux, où tu as des community managers, etc., qui, eux, ont les techniques, effectivement, pour bien référencer les articles, pour bien les poster au bon moment, etc.
Et ça, le journaliste, en tout cas, dans un premier temps, on lui a pas demandé d'intégrer ça dans sa manière de faire son métier.
Ce qu'on lui demande en priorité, c'est d'avoir de bonnes infos, qu'elles soient bien expliquées, bien restituées, avec les bonnes sources, bien écrites, etc.
Et donc ça, je dirais, si déjà, on pouvait faire cette partie-là du métier le mieux possible, je dirais, ce serait déjà très bien.
Je suis pas sûr-- donner de leçons à personne, mais ça reste un vrai problème dans la profession, en Belgique comme ailleurs.
On voit bien, voilà, qu'il y a de bons médias, y a de bons journalistes, y en a des moins bons.
Et donc, c'est-- à chaque fois, ne pas justement être submergé et dépassé par l'aspect technologique pour s'écarter de ces fondamentaux et ces règles de bon journalisme, de qualité journalistique.
Je crois que si y a un moyen pour les médias menacés, moi, c'est depuis que je travaille, on dit que la presse est en crise et je crois qu'elle est effectivement en crise économique.
Mais si y a un moyen pour elle de s'en sortir, c'est justement de revenir à ces fondamentaux de qualité, de valeur ajoutée, comme on dit aujourd'hui, pour effectivement continuer à séduire et attirer,
des clients, parce qu'on est sur un marché et que y a, voilà, y a pas de secret.
Si on veut que les gens viennent vers nous dans un monde où l'information n'a jamais été aussi abondante, bah il faut qu'on fasse la différence, qu'on vienne avec des contenus de qualité, traités de manière rigoureuse, et pas du,
simplement des titres qui vont cliquer, ou des photos qui vont faire, je dirais, un peu le buzz.
Tu évoquais à l'instant cette volonté d'aller en profondeur et de créer une plus-value journalistique. Je voulais rebondir là-dessus en évoquant l'article de Frédéric Chardon, c'est ça ?
Oui. Il y a quelques jours, où il faisait une analyse des relations franco-belges-
Oui
...au jour du match-
Du match, oui
...de demi-finale ce soir d'ailleurs. Donc, je le trouvais très intéressant.
Oui.
Je trouvais qu'il n'allait pas assez en profondeur-
Tout à fait
...et qu'il s'arrêtait trop tôt et que-
Oui
...je me disais, mais finalement-
Tu restais sur ta faim
...c'est-- il n'y a pas cette place pour écrire la fin de l'article-
Oui
...puisqu'il y a une grosse publicité juste en dessous de l'article.
Oui, c'est vrai. Alors, maintenant, oui, c'est vrai. On peut isoler un cas ou un-
Bien sûr, bien sûr, oui. C'est peut-être anecdotique.
Par contre-- non, je dis pas que c'est anecdotique, mais c'est vrai qu'il faut voir les circonstances dans lesquelles il a dû rédiger cet article.
Je crois que les gens de l'extérieur ne se rendent pas toujours compte non plus des conditions dans lesquelles parfois des articles doivent être écrits.
Je veux dire, on n'arrive pas comme ça au journal, à la rédaction,
le matin et puis où on connaît déjà son sujet à l'avance et où on se donne au moins une journée pour bien le rédiger, donner les coups de téléphone ou voir les gens qui peuvent éventuellement enrichir le contenu.
Cet article-là, puisque j'étais présent à la rédaction, il s'est fait un dimanche, il s'est-- il n'avait-
Il voulait partir en quarter, donc il n'avait pas le temps.
Voilà, il y en avait d'autres qui l'attendaient, etc. Donc c'est vrai que parfois, bon voilà, il faut admettre que des choses sont écrites rapidement.
Ça veut pas dire qu'elles sont de mauvaise qualité, mais voilà, parfois, on doit réagir vite. Ce sujet-là nous paraissait intéressant, mais Frédéric n'avait pas non plus trois heures devant lui pour faire un article.
Mais sinon, on essaie quand même, parce que si La Libre se résumait à de petits articles un peu superficiels, je pense qu'à mon avis, on serait déjà disparu.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est un exercice, c'est pas évident, hein, parce qu'on est,
on est entré, pour revenir à l'aspect technologique de ta question, on est entré depuis quelques années, c'est vrai, dans une sorte de,
de courant où toutes les choses, où tout s'est accéléré, où on veut être les premiers à donner l'information, on veut surtout avoir les informations que les autres n'ont pas.
Et donc, c'est source de danger, parce que c'est source de superficialité dans le traitement. Ça peut être source d'imprécision, le fait de ne pas prendre le temps de vérifier l'information.
Et tout ça, c'est des choses, voilà, il faut trouver le bon équilibre entre le fait que c'est vrai qu'avec les réseaux sociaux, eh bah y a une prime à celui qui arrive le premier, hein, qui donne l'information le premier,
beaucoup plus qu'avant avec les journaux papier.
D'un autre côté, si c'est pour être le premier, mais finalement galvauder un peu la qualité de la marque, hein, de la marque Libre ou la marque Soir, etc.
Je pense qu'à terme, c'est un très mauvais calcul parce qu'on va déprécier cette marque et que les lecteurs ne viendront plus chez nous.
Mh. Et donc, est-ce que c'est justement pour créer cette plus-value, cette valeur ajoutée que vous faites beaucoup de contributions externes dans La Libre Belgique ?
Alors, ça, c'est vraiment oui. Ça, c'est un choix vraiment éditorial. Donc, et c'est une des spécificités de La Libre.
Ça veut pas dire qu'on est les seuls à le faire, mais en tout cas, c'est un choix qu'on a fait, mais ça, il y a déjà quelques années.
C'était au début des années 2000, quand on a fait une refonte assez fondamentale du journal, pas uniquement de la maquette et pas uniquement une refonte graphique, mais aussi, on s'est réinterrogé un peu sur
quelles sont finalement nos forces,
en termes de contenu, partant du principe ou du postulat que La Libre Belgique, vu les moyens qui sont les siens, ne peut pas courir derrière tout.
Il y a des journaux qui essayent de tout faire. Depuis l'information, le fait divers-
Qu'est-ce que vous ne faites pas, par exemple ?
Bah par exemple, nous, on n'est clairement pas un journal régional, même si on a des pages qui parlent-
Pour chaque province, ouais
...mais ce sont deux pages, trois pages maximum, où effectivement, on donne le minimum, je dirais, ce qu'il faut un peu savoir dans...
Mais notre raison d'être, c'est pas ça. Je veux dire, si la personne cherche de l'information locale, il va se diriger vers une presse beaucoup plus
régionale ou locale, comme L'Avenir, comme SudPresse, qui, elle, va se donner les moyens, a un réseau.
Nous, on n'a pas un réseau de correspondants régionaux qui nous permettent vraiment de nous profiler comme un journal régional.
Par contre, il y a quatre, cinq domaines dans lesquels on veut être de qualité. On ne veut pas, je dirais pas les meilleurs, mais où on essaye vraiment d'être bon, c'est la politique.
La politique belge, ça, c'est depuis de tout temps, La Libre a été un journal en pointe sur l'information politique.
Je vais pas refaire un-
Un historique
...un historique, parce qu'effectivement, il y a eu dans cette couverture politique différentes phases, hein. Il y a un moment, on a été très proche d'une famille politique pendant très longtemps.
On s'est émancipé sur le plan, justement, de ce reproche qui nous est encore fait aujourd'hui, mais qui, selon moi, n'a plus de raison d'être.
C'est pas parce que tu défends des valeurs que tu es proche d'un parti politique. Parfois, les gens font un peu l'amalgame en disant : « Oui, comme ils
défendent telles valeurs, les valeurs chrétiennes, par exemple, ils sont forcément un journal, le journal du CDH.
» Bon, c'est un peu caricatural.
Ces contributions externes, y en a notamment monsieur, monsieur Dujardin-
Oui
...qui s'est présenté sur les listes à Woluwe-Saint-Pierre.
Sur le MR, je pense, oui.
Oui, c'est ça, voilà.
Qui n'est plus maintenant contributeur depuis qu'il est justement, il s'est présenté-
D'accord
...il a été candidat aux élections communales, je pense.
Oui, oui, ça a du sens, oui. Mais donc, justement, c'est quelqu'un qui était, qui est plutôt d'une droite dure-
Oui, qui-
...qui explique qu'on a besoin d'avoir une NVA du côté francophone-
Tout à fait
...qui défend, qui approuve la droitisation du MR-
Oui, du MR
...ces dernières années-
Au même titre que Destexhe, oui.
Mais donc, bon, cette position-là, vous la ressentiez déjà, j'imagine, du temps où il était contributeur dans l'image du journal.
Oui, oui, tout à fait, mais-
Est-ce que justement, le fait d'avoir de tels contributeurs dans le journal ne participe pas à orienter un petit peu politiquement La Libre Belgique ?
Oui, si ce n'était que des contributions venant de cet horizon politique qui est très à droite, comme tu le dis, je pense qu'effectivement, à ce moment-là, on serait perçu exclusivement comme un journal-
De droite
...de droite et avec des relents réactionnaires. Mais je pense qu'effectivement, la qualité de La Libre fait que le débat est ouvert.
C'était un de nos slogans, il y a quelques années, qu'on donne la parole à beaucoup d'autres
sensibilités, qu'elles soient de droite comme de gauche ou du centre, qui font que, je--
si tu te limites évidemment à une semaine et tu te dis : « Ouais, ils ont donné la parole à un tel ou à un tel », on va dire que c'est un journal de droite.
Bon OK. Si tu prends la peine d'analyser toutes les contributions qu'on donne, je sais pas moi, sur une année, on peut faire l'exercice, c'est une image beaucoup plus nuancée et pluraliste.
Et c'est vraiment, on veut être un journal
pluraliste. Ça veut pas dire que le journal lui-même n'a pas une ligne éditoriale
et des valeurs, mais en tout cas, quand il donne la parole à des contributions extérieures, il a vraiment la préoccupation de refléter un maximum de positions-
Une certaine pluralité.
'Fin de pluralisme, pardon. Ce qui veut pas dire qu'effectivement, il y a des personnes peut-être que tu ne liras rarement ou que très rarement dans La Libre ou pas du tout, parce que soit elles sont vraiment aux extrêmes,
ou parce qu'elles ne sont pas représentatives.
Si c'est donner la parole à monsieur
X qui, voilà, qui ne représente que lui, bon, ça s'appelle du courrier des lecteurs, on peut le faire, mais de là à donner des opinions et de l'espace à des personnes qui ne représentent qu'eux, avec en plus des idées complètement,
voilà, qui ne rentrent pas dans le débat démocratique, on ne voit pas très bien la raison pour laquelle on doit les accueillir.
Mais j'ai pas terminé sur les-
Je t'en prie, vas-y
...les points forts, en fait. Donc j'avais commencé la politique. Il y a la politique internationale où La Libre aussi a toujours voulu être une référence.
Il y a l'information économique et financière.
Ça, c'est toi.
C'est pas moi, c'est moi et mes collègues. Et il y a la culture. Parce que tu me disais : « Mais qu'est-ce que vous ne faites pas ?
» Et donc ça, c'est vraiment les quatre domaines dans lesquels on veut vraiment être présent. Ce qui veut pas dire qu'on ne donne pas du sport, qu'on ne donne pas de l'information locale ou régionale, qu'on ne donne pas du fait divers.
Mais voilà, compte tenu de nos moyens, on essaye aussi de mettre nos forces sur ces quatre grands domaines.
Alors, on va passer sur un autre gros dossier. On va remonter quelques années en arrière. Tu étais rédacteur en chef adjoint en 2005, 2006.
Oui.
À l'époque où vous aviez fait une grosse attaque, un gros procès contre Google News.
Oui, oui.
Est-ce que tu peux nous parler de cette époque-là et de ce qui vous a guidé à ce moment-là ?
Alors, ce qu'il faut bien comprendre, c'est que, d'une certaine façon, le procès en tant que tel, il a été mené par les éditeurs, donc regroupés au sein des journaux francophones belges.
Ça s'appelait CopyPress, c'est ça ?
Dans CopyPress, si tu veux, ça, c'était un peu tout ce qui était effectivement lié à la reproduction de contenus protégés par le droit d'auteur.
Et puis, tu avais notamment les éditeurs, donc les patrons de presse, qui, eux, avaient une association qui s'appelle les JFB, qu'on appelle maintenant LaPresse.be.
Et c'est eux, vraiment eux qui ont été les fers de lance dans cette réaction par rapport à Google, même si derrière Google, il y avait d'autres acteurs émergents à ce moment-là.
Mais Google, c'est vrai, était le plus puissant. Et donc c'est eux qui vraiment, de façon concertée, donc c'est pas le patron de La Libre, c'est pas le patron du Soir, qui à un moment ont vu effectivement l'impact,
que pouvait avoir la récupération de contenus venant de nos médias, pour alimenter leur fil Google News.
Leur plateforme, oui.
Voilà. Et donc, ils ont vraiment, à un moment, ils ont tiré la sonnette d'alarme en disant : « Bon, on est en train de piller nos contenus et il est pas normal que ce ne soit pas contre rétribution.
» Et donc c'est comme ça que les choses ont commencé. Il y a eu vraiment une saga judiciaire dont d'ailleurs j'étais souvent un peu perdu.
Et chaque fois que je devais écrire un-- 'fin, devais, devais pas, mais que j'écrivais un papier sur le sujet, c'est vrai que suivre ça était très compliqué.
Et donc moi, je l'ai suivi, mais de manière un peu distante pour essayer quand même de tenir nos lecteurs informés qui comprennent le pourquoi de la réaction des éditeurs et de La Libre en particulier.
C'est ça. Et donc, mais tu as l'air de dire que c'est une bataille qui s'est menée avant tout par les dirigeants-
Oui, tout à fait
...et pas tellement par les journalistes.
Non.
Donc, idéologiquement, est-ce que-- parce que quand on lisait justement tes articles sur le sujet, on sentait que c'était assez orienté, qu'il y avait-
Oui, tout à fait
...il y avait les gentils, il y avait les méchants de l'autre côté.
Oui, et c'était vraiment... Oui. Et je peux le comprendre parce que je suppose qu'on va parler aussi de l'épisode-
Oui, oui, on va y arriver. On va y arriver
...de la réforme sur le droit d'auteur au niveau européen. Je crois que les journalistes-- alors moi, j'étais peut-être,
enfin moi, ici au sein de La Libre, mais d'autres journalistes qui suivent un peu le secteur des médias, on découvrait pas la chose.
On savait que effectivement, la montée en puissance de Google et la manière dont,
il prenait de plus en plus de parts de marché publicitaire et donc, cette part de marché publicitaire, elle était gagnée et rognée sur celle des éditeurs des médias classiques.
C'est devenu-- quand l'affaire a éclaté, c'était vraiment une bagarre d'entreprise. C'était David contre Goliath.
Et donc c'était les petits éditeurs belges francophones contre le géant de Mountain View. Et donc c'est vrai que moi, en tant que journaliste d'un, finalement, d'un petit journal au niveau mondial,
c'est vrai que je me mettais effectivement dans la peau de celui qui est assiégé par le géant Google, avec aussi tout ce que ça peut représenter en termes de schizophrénie ou d'hypocrisie.
On est les premiers aussi à utiliser Google quand ça nous arrange. Google, voilà, qui est une boîte assez géniale parce que quand même, voilà, c'est assez génial comme histoire.
Google a l'intelligence aujourd'hui de venir financer des projets journalistiques, à travers des initiatives Digital News Initiative dont nous avons aussi bénéficié.
Donc quand je dis schizophrénie, c'est parce que voilà, d'un côté, on voit bien que c'est une menace parce qu'ils viennent manger une partie de nos ressources et de plus en plus grande.
Et de l'autre côté, on voit qu'eux essayent évidemment de trouver des-- ils ont besoin de nous, ils ont besoin des médias, du contenu.
Hein, le contenu, c'est quand même ce que les gens vont chercher sur Google ou sur d'autres réseaux. Et nos contenus les intéressent.
Et donc voilà, Google n'a jamais évidemment accepté de payer des droits d'auteur au sens classique du terme, mais ils ont essayé par d'autres canaux de dire : « Mais voilà, on aimerait bien être vos partenaires.
» Et donc un type de partenariat, c'est notamment le financement de projets journalistiques de plus long terme. Et voilà.
Mais donc c'est très compliqué à traiter comme sujet parce qu'effectivement, on est un peu partisan.
Moi, en tant que journaliste qui écrit ça dans un journal classique qui fait partie de ces acteurs qui attaquent Google en justice,
voilà, ça fait partie de ces sujets qui sont délicats à traiter et qui sont intéressants à traiter, mais voilà, forcément, on écrit d'un point de vue et,
et de l'extérieur, ça peut apparaître comme quelque chose de déséquilibré ou très partiel.
Mais justement, pour continuer là-dessus, on a beaucoup parlé ces dernières semaines, comme tu le disais, de ce projet de réforme au Parlement européen, cette directive.
On va revenir dessus dans un instant. J'étais assez choqué de voir à quel point, selon la source que je lisais, le projet de loi était soit génial, soit la pire chose du monde.
Ça fait un-- bon, j'exagère un tout petit peu, mais ça fait un petit peu écho à la situation en Amérique où selon si on regarde Fox News ou MSNBC, on vit sur deux planètes complètement différentes.
Oui, c'est vrai.
Il y a pour certains un mythe comme quoi être journaliste, c'est viser l'objectivité. Pour le coup, c'est assez clair que l'objectivité n'existe pas et qu'on est soit pour, soit contre.
C'est très subjectif.
Je vais parler pour La Libre.
Oui.
Dans le cas précis de la réforme des droits d'auteur, à mon avis, t'as pas dû retrouver beaucoup d'articles sous mon nom.
Non, mais je t'ai demandé directement sur Twitter et tu m'as dit : « Je partage l'avis de cet article. »
Oui, parce que tu m'as interrogé. Mais dans le papier que j'ai écrit, on a écrit très peu de choses en fait, dans l'arrivée du projet en plénière à Strasbourg.
En fait, j'ai écrit un papier au départ d'une dépêche AFP que je trouvais très bien faite. D'ailleurs, j'avais mis PFL avec AFP entre parenthèses
et qui était-- dans ce papier-là, tu ne peux pas-- je présentais les-- je faisais un flashback sur le fait qu'en commission du Parlement, le projet avait été approuvé, de manière,
très juste et que ça arrivait en plé-- j'étais vraiment dans le descriptif, c'est ça que je veux dire.
Par contre, c'est vrai que le jour même ou la veille,
notre administrateur délégué, donc le patron de La Libre Belgique,
dans les pages débats et opinions de La Libre, a pris la parole et donc a rédigé un texte pour dire que c'était une catastrophe si jamais
les eurodéputés n'approuvaient pas ce projet de réforme tel qu'il arrivait et qui était le fruit d'un compromis, puisqu'il y a eu un lobbying, mais intense, aussi bien des GAFA que des
patrons de presse.
Et donc, par contre, on n'a pas fait d'éditoriaux. Un journal concurrent a décidé de faire un éditorial en marquant clairement-
Sa position, ouais
...son point de vue, sa position. Je respecte ça et probablement que si on avait fait un éditorial, on aurait été dans le même sens.
Par contre, là aussi, dans ce journal-là, il y avait un article qu'on peut éventuellement juger partiel, mais qui donnait quand même des éléments d'information et qui était pas-
Il était très partiel.
D'accord, je vais pas me prononcer.
C'est carrément partiel.
Oui, mais chez nous, en tout cas, c'était pas le méchant GAFA, les méchants GAFA. Et le lendemain, quand le vote, finalement, le projet a été rejeté, c'est vrai qu'on a-- probablement qu'on a dû titrer en disant :
« Les éditeurs perdent contre les GAFA », mais on n'a pas mis les méchants GAFA, même si les sous-entendus peuvent évidemment être assez évidents.
Voilà, mais sur le fond du dossier...
Non, on va-- sur le fond du dossier, on va y revenir dans un instant, mais avant d'aller là-dessus, je voulais simplement approfondir la question de la partialité, justement.
Est-ce que quand on est journaliste, on a le sentiment, en plus de simplement relayer l'actualité, de participer à façonner le monde, à relayer une certaine idéologie ?
Comment est-ce que tu vois ?
Oui, oui, oui, moi, je crois clairement. Donc, c'est un peu bateau de le dire, mais l'objectivité, la neutralité n'existent pas en journalisme.
Je crois qu'on est des-- tu traites l'information toujours d'un point de vue. Je veux dire, tu n'es pas neutre quand tu poses un regard sur un fait d'actualité.
Tu as beau dire : « Je vais coller à l'actualité » et, comme disent les Anglo-Saxons, « facts, facts, facts ».
La manière dont tu écris déjà, la manière dont tu vas sélectionner, hiérarchiser les faits, va être façonnée par ce que tu es, mais aussi par l'employeur, le journal pour lequel tu travailles.
Donc moi, je ne prétends certainement pas à ne pas véhiculer un... Alors l'idéologie, ça, c'est déjà un next step, c'est-à-dire que l'idéologie, ça veut dire qu'on s'inscrit dans un cadre pratiquement déjà
prédéterminé auquel tout le monde devrait, comme les Dix Commandements,
Mh
on devrait suivre. Ça, ça va pas jusque-là.
La seule chose, c'est que la rédaction de La Libre, et La Libre a une histoire, a des valeurs et qu'on est tous nourris là-dessus, mais c'est pas des valeurs figées, c'est des valeurs qui évoluent avec le temps.
J'en parlais tout à l'heure par rapport au traitement de l'actualité politique. Entre la manière d'entretenir la politique il y a 20 ans ou 30 ans et maintenant, il y a un monde de différence.
Et ceux qui veulent vraiment prendre la peine de l'observer le verront. C'est la même chose dans le domaine de l'économie, de la culture, etc.
Mais moi, en tant que journaliste, c'est vrai que je,
je vais privilégier... Voilà, plutôt... Dans le domaine de l'entrepreneuriat, par exemple, et des entreprises,
voilà, je suis pas neutre de la façon dont je vais plutôt privilégier telle ou telle société, tel secteur, parce que j'ai des affinités avec certains secteurs, avec certaines personnes
et que je vais plutôt aller vers elles.
Et donc tout ça va influencer mon travail.
Mh.
Maintenant, au-delà de ça, le tout, c'est de bien le faire quand même. C'est pas parce que, voilà, tu donneras peut-être la préférence à un interlocuteur ou une boîte.
Il faut le faire sérieusement. Je veux dire, c'est,
c'est là qu'il y a un contrat avec le lecteur. Parce que si c'est juste faire la promotion de la boîte de mes petits copains, je veux dire, quelle est la valeur de l'information que je véhicule ?
Il faut quand même que j'aie un regard très large, très critique, complet. Et ça, c'est, voilà, c'est pour ça qu'on est des
Oui
professionnels.
Pendant longtemps, les journalistes, ceux qui travaillaient pour un journal, pour une télévision ou pour une radio,
aujourd'hui, avec les nouveaux médias, on voit arriver ceux qu'on appelle les influenceurs ou, de manière générale, ceux qui créent du contenu de manière plus artisanale, plus amateur,
les podcasts, les chaînes YouTube, etc.
Les frontières se brouillent en quelque sorte. Qu'est-ce qui fait la différence pour toi entre un influenceur, pour appeler ça comme ça, et un journaliste ?
Bonne question. Moi, ces influenceurs, je les... Parce qu'un journaliste, on va dire traditionnel, comme je le suis, peut devenir un influenceur
Mh
dans son domaine, dans la manière dont il va traiter les sujets, etc. Donc parfois, les deux se recoupent.
En fait, je vais peut-être un petit peu
Oui
préciser ma question. Est-ce que est journaliste le premier qui se dit journaliste ? Est-ce qu'on est journaliste seulement si on travaille pour les grands médias ?
Est-ce qu'on peut être journaliste si on fait une chaîne YouTube dans sa chambre ? Comment est-ce que tu vois ça ?
C'est vrai que tu fais bien de poser la question. C'est que tout le monde peut être journaliste.
D'accord.
En fait, il n'y a aucun diplôme nécessaire pour accéder à la profession de journaliste. C'est un des rares métiers d'ailleurs.
Quand tu veux être médecin, ben tu dois avoir un diplôme de médecine.
Ce serait dangereux si c'était le cas. C'est un peu comme en Ouganda où tu dois payer, je crois que c'est en Ouganda, où tu dois payer 1 000 euros pour avoir le droit d'avoir une chaîne YouTube ou...
Ah oui, oui, oui. Mais c'est vrai que c'est quand même particulier. C'est-à-dire, le droit d'informer est un droit qui est reconnu à tout le monde.
Maintenant, je pense que c'est la manière dont... 'Fin, c'est, un média, il va acquérir un certain succès, il va réunir une communauté dès lors qu'il instaure une confiance avec cette communauté.
Et cette confiance, elle passe par le fait qu'une rédaction est composée de gens de qualité qui suivent un certain nombre de règles qui sont pas des règles,
forcément toutes écrites et dictées dans la loi, mais qui... Les règles de déontologie, par exemple, ce sont des règles que la profession elle-même a définies et qu'on s'engage tous à respecter.
Et parfois, elles ne sont pas respectées et il y a des rappels à l'ordre. Donc, je dirais, être journaliste, aujourd'hui, tout le monde peut devenir journaliste, surtout avec les technologies.
Donc, on peut ouvrir une chaîne YouTube, on peut ouvrir un blog du jour au lendemain. Maintenant, je pense que n'est pas... Pour avoir une audience, c'est encore autre chose.
Pour construire une audience, c'est pas, à moins de s'appeler, 'fin d'avoir vraiment un nom qui
Mh
qui rassemble et qui fait autorité, c'est très compliqué d'être seul derrière son blog et de réunir des grosses audiences.
Tu vas me dire : « Oui, sur YouTube, il y a des gars qui font des millions de vues, etc. »
Sur YouTube, il y a des gars qui font des millions de vues.
Ils font rarement du journalisme. C'est plutôt des amuseurs publics. Ils font de l'infotainment, comme on dit.
C'est-à-dire que j'appelle pas ça du travail journalistique, mais tu as peut-être des exemples sérieux et qui probablement existent, de gens qui, à travers YouTube, se sont révélés être d'excellents journalistes.
C'est possible. En Belgique, j'en connais pas, en tout cas.
Non, mais la Belgique est un petit marché.
Mais c'est vrai que c'est un tout petit marché. Mais donc voilà, c'est compliqué de répondre à la question. Je pense que moi, si j'étais Pierre-François Lovens seul et que je créais mon média, j'aurais énormément de difficultés.
Par contre, le fait que Pierre-François Lovens travaille à La Libre, au Soir ou à L'Écho, ça lui donne une légitimité, tu vois ?
D'accord, OK.
Donc il y a la question de la légitimité aussi.
La question de la légitimité, la question de l'audience, de la taille du public.
Voilà, oui.
Et donc, in fine, la question de la rémunération et de savoir vivre de son travail.
Voilà, exactement. Et oui, c'est ça aussi. Si c'est juste une activité complémentaire, mais qui ne te permette pas de vivre...
C'est un peu ce que moi, je fais quand j'écris des papiers...
Oui, oui. Ceci étant, il faut l'admettre, dans la profession de journaliste, malheureusement, il y a beaucoup de jeunes, notamment, qui sont précarisés parce qu'ils sont pas bien payés et que quand tu commences comme jeune journaliste
et que tu... Non seulement tu dois faire tes preuves, acquérir une certaine
légitimité au-delà de la légitimité du média pour lequel tu travailles, mais tu dois toi-même montrer que tu es à la hauteur du média pour lequel tu travailles.
Mais bon, voilà, je veux dire, la qualité, ça se paye. Malheureusement, il y a beaucoup de jeunes journalistes qui sont pas... qui rament.
Moi, j'ai eu la chance de commencer dans un média qui a accepté d'emblée de m'accorder un contrat de salarié,
mais je me rends compte que j'ai eu énormément de chance et qu'aujourd'hui, la plupart des jeunes journalistes, ben ils commencent comme indépendants. Que
Comme pigistes.
Ils restent comme pigistes, oui. Et avant de gagner ta vie convenablement, il faut déjà...
Mmh, chose pas facile.
Il faut glisser de la copie. De la bonne copie.
Oui, en plus. On va maintenant enchaîner et parler justement de cette directive européenne,
Oui
le Copyright in the Digital Single Market,
qui sera débattu en septembre au Parlement européen. On va s'attarder dans un premier temps sur l'article 11 qui, en gros, cible assez...
C'est pas dit explicitement, mais c'est un petit peu l'article Google News quoi.
Mmh.
Donc pour ceux qui n'ont pas suivi, l'idée de ce texte de l'article 11, c'est de créer un droit voisin pour les médias.
Mmh-mmh.
Donc si je suis une société du Web et que je veux faire un lien vers La Libre Belgique, afficher le titre de l'article, une photo, un extrait de l'article,
Mmh
je dois demander la permission de La Libre Belgique et probablement aussi la question des royalties. Plus précisément, dans le texte,
Mmh-mmh
il est précisé que ça s'applique aux grandes sociétés du Web, mais ça n'est pas défini très clairement puisque c'est une directive européenne et que ce sera aux États membres de préciser,
Oui, voilà, donc ça devrait être appliqué dans les droits nationaux, voire même dans les droits régionaux, communautaires, concernant la Belgique.
Première question : pourquoi est-ce que vous voulez faire ça ?
Attends, moi, je ne veux pas le faire ça.
Non, non, mais votre média soutient ouvertement le projet de loi.
Oui, d'accord, mais moi, je... Non, non, mais c'est un... Je peux donner mon avis sur la question.
Bien sûr.
Moi, je ne revendique pas que ce soit ça. Je comprends tout à fait et je soutiens le fait que mon entreprise et d'autres entreprises de presse revendiquent ça.
Ça, c'est clair. Pourquoi ? Parce que... Je vais prendre un exemple très simple. Quand quelqu'un veut utiliser un de mes articles, la première chose qu'il fait, si...
La plupart du temps, c'est qu'il me téléphone en disant : « Pierre-François, j'ai vu que tu avais écrit un article.
Est-ce que je peux l'utiliser pour le mettre, par exemple, sur ma plateforme, mon blog ? » Dans le domaine des start-up, ça arrive souvent.
Quand tu veux dire l'utiliser, tu veux dire mettre un lien ou le copier-coller ?
Ça peut être les deux. Ça peut être les deux, c'est-à-dire que
Les deux sont quand même assez différents.
Oui, OK. Mais juste terminer cet exemple-là. Par exemple, dans le cas des start-up, souvent, les start-up aiment, sur leur site Internet, montrer que des médias ont parlé d'eux.
Et donc, ils vont aller mettre un lien ou copier-coller, mais souvent, c'est un lien avec le logo du média. Mais pour faire ça, ils vont en principe demander la permission.
C'est là-dedans... C'est là qu'on arrive dans la question du droit voisin, puisque actuellement, on est dans une situation où le copier-coller complet de l'article et puis éventuellement, on oublie de mettre le nom et la source, voilà. Là, c'est
une pratique qui est sanctionnée par la loi. Là où on arrive dans la question du droit voisin et de cette directive européenne,
on passerait dans un scénario où mettre un lien, le titre de l'article, une photo, un petit extrait seraient soumis aux mêmes règles, c'est-à-dire, il faut demander la permission et éventuellement payer des royalties.
Je comprends.
C'est une distinction importante à faire.
Tout à fait, oui. Et honnêtement, moi, je ne prétends pas être un spécialiste de la question pour dire jusqu'à quel moment...
Parce que Google, ce qu'il faisait avant, c'est qu'il mettait quand même
L'intégralité.
Et ça, ça n'est pas permis et ils ont été sanctionnés.
Exactement.
Aujourd'hui, la loi demande l'étape suivante, c'est-à-dire le droit voisin.
Il y a une évolution. Et d'ailleurs, c'est le projet de loi, 'fin la proposition de directive
C'est ça
qui était soumise, c'était ça.
C'était de permettre quand même, 'fin si j'ai bien compris, parce que j'ai pas assisté au débat de la Commission en commission du Parlement européen, c'est que, à partir du moment où on,
où on donne un contenu sur Google auquel tout internaute peut accéder alors que ce contenu est protégé, ben c'est là qu'on demande rémunération.
Si c'est juste mettre un lien, mais sans... Juste avec le titre de l'article, mais sans donner, par exemple, les dix premières lignes de l'article, c'est juste cliquer sur un lien.
À ma connaissance, les éditeurs ne demandent pas d'être rémunérés pour ça. Mais sous réserve de vérifier.
Qu'est-ce qui change alors entre la situation aujourd'hui et la situation post-entrée en vigueur de cette loi ?
Mais elle n'est pas entrée en vigueur.
Non, non, mais le jour où c'est le cas.
Mais c'est que avant, Google faisait des copier-coller, on pouvait accéder à des contenus comme ça, à tout venant. Donc...
Tu parles de quand on va voir le cache d'un...
Oui, oui.
Et alors à ce moment-là, les publicités ne sont pas affichées, c'est ça ?
Alors là, techniquement, je sais même pas si les publicités sont affichées ou pas. Ça, c'est quelque chose, par exemple, je n'ai jamais été vérifié.
C'est ça.
Moi, c'était le contenu journalistique de l'article qui était accessible, sans devoir, sans barrière, sans paywall, je dirais.
Par contre, aujourd'hui, avec la réforme du droit d'auteur, selon moi, mais peut-être que je me trompe
Mmh
c'est le fait que on donne plus comme ça accès gratuitement à des contenus que Google va chercher et importe sur sa plateforme. Non ?
Non.
Donne-moi ton interprétation de l'article 11.
La question du droit voisin, c'est que c'est plus seulement l'article dans son intégralité qui est protégé par le droit d'auteur et que
Oui
effectivement, celui qui va le copier-coller sera un pirate et sera sanctionné par la loi. Ce sera que carrément, peut-être de copier-coller le titre, simplement le titre, éventuellement une photo
Très payant
sera soumis au droit d'auteur. Il faudra demander la permission
Autorisation
au média qui le possède. Et c'est là, effectivement, qu'on voit qu'il y a des interprétations différentes et pas forcément
Oui, oui
justes, pas forcément conformes à la réalité. C'est que certains décrivaient la situation comme quoi on ne pourra plus partager les articles sur Facebook, parce qu'il faudra à chaque fois demander la permission de La Libre.
Dans les faits, ce que dit l'article, c'est que ça ne s'appliquera qu'aux très grandes sociétés, sans non plus définir exactement ce que ça signifie, dans quel contexte.
Donc c'est pour ça qu'il y avait un peu de flou.
Il y a du flou.
Et c'est pour ça qu'il y avait une certaine opposition. Et donc, oui, mais les articles qui sont payants, par exemple sur La Libre Belgique, par exemple celui
où tu parles de moi, si tu fais une recherche Google et que tu vas avoir le cache
Tu sauras pas le
Y aura toujours une barrière qui dit : « Il faut payer ». Ça, ça n'est pas... Google n'a pas des pouvoirs magiques pour faire disparaître les paywall.
Non, d'accord, OK. Mais le problème, c'est que, comme tu dis toi-même, c'est encore trop flou pour voir exactement quelles sont les plateformes qui vont être concernées.
Déjà, oui.
Ces grands acteurs.
Et dans quel... Mais moi, je n'ai... Mais tu as probablement raison, je n'avais pas compris jusqu'ici, parce que l'article 11 ne perm... 'fin, moi, je trouve qu'il n'est pas suffisamment, il ne permet pas d'aller jusque-là.
Et en plus de ça, je dirais que la couverture médiatique de cet article 11 a été, comme je disais, certains le décrivaient comme étant, comme tu dis, un truc horrible qui allait rendre tout le contenu payant gratuit, etc.
Et donc, effectivement, je pense que c'est aussi une question des sources qu'on a consommées.
Alors, je crois qu'au-delà de l'aspect technique, à partir de quel moment le média va demander à la plateforme de payer,
je pense qu'au-delà de ce qu'on fera de cet article 11 et comment on va le traduire dans les législations nationales, je pense que la position de principe que les éditeurs ont aussi,
c'est le fait qu'eux, pour produire ces contenus et les commercialiser, mais pour les produire, ils ont derrière eux effectivement une série de coûts, dont les journalistes, et qu'il est normal,
alors c'est là où on peut discuter, que des plateformes comme Google, Facebook...
Google News, ouais, ouais
...payent leur part pour pouvoir utiliser ce contenu-là. Comme effectivement le consommateur de La Libre ou du Soir paye effectivement son droit d'accéder au contenu...
Et ici, quand on parle de contenu, on parle donc de, bah simplement un petit extrait, un titre, une photo telle que c'est présenté, par exemple, sur Google News.
Et donc cette question de participer, de payer les médias pour...
Oui
...utiliser une partie de leur contenu, c'est une loi qui est déjà entrée en vigueur en Espagne, où, bah, ce qu'on appelle dans les faits une taxe Google News.
Puis Google s'est retiré.
Bah Google, oui, Google News, en tout cas, a disparu de l'Espagne.
Mais ce qu'ils ont fait en Belgique à un moment aussi hein, puis ils sont revenus, mais...
Oui, oui, tout à fait. Mais d'après la presse espagnole, suite au retrait de Google News, ils ont perdu un bon gros paquet de trafic.
Donc c'est une question que je voulais te poser. Est-ce que finalement, Google News, en termes d'importance, de trafic, est-ce que c'est important aux yeux de La Libre Belgique ?
Oui.
Ou bien est-ce que finalement...
Google et Facebook.
Pourquoi vous leur tapez dessus alors ?
Non, parce que finalement, y a eu quand même, y a eu à un moment une sorte de... quand les éditeurs, effectivement, ont attaqué Google News en...
2005, 2006, oui.
Google News a eu la même attitude qu'en Espagne. Ils se sont retirés et nous, on a vu effectivement une chute de fréquentation de notre site.
En plus de s'être retirés, ils vous ont complètement déréférencés des moteurs de recherche. Et donc, si on cherchait un article, on n'arrivait pas à le trouver.
Exactement. Et on a vu que ça nous faisait beaucoup de tort. Et donc après, y a eu, voilà, ils ont fait un peu marche arrière, et ils ont essayé de trouver effectivement un terrain d'entente, parce que
la fréquentation de nos sites, c'est un secret pour personne, je veux dire, le rôle joué, l'impact des réseaux sociaux et des plateformes est énorme.
Bien sûr.
Je pourrais pas te dire des chiffres comme ça, mais ils sont connus et tu peux les retrouver. Mais voilà, on sait que si tu mets Google plus Facebook, plus éventuellement l'un ou l'autre,
je sais pas moi, Twitter, Instagram, LinkedIn, etc,
bah t'arrives, voilà...
95 % quoi.
Je sais pas. Honnêtement, je ne connais pas les chiffres et j'ai peur de dire des bêtises, mais c'est une grosse, grosse partie des internautes qui arrivent sur le site de La Libre via ces plateformes-là.
Et donc c'est là un peu où on doit, voilà, où c'est pas facile.
Vous mordez la main qui vous nourrit.
Oui, mais c'est... oui, mais ça aussi, ça vaut aussi pour eux. Alors maintenant, eux, ils sont dans une position de force, ils ont une puissance financière, une surface incroyable, mais eux ont besoin de nous aussi.
C'est vrai qu'on est le Petit Poucet là-dedans, mais eux, pour rendre leur plateforme intéressante, ils ont besoin de...
De contenu
...de contenu intéressant. Alors maintenant, Facebook, à un moment, a fait le pari de se dire : « Oui, finalement, on va modifier l'algorithme pour ne plus privilégier les contenus de type journalistique news ».
Bah, je pense que... et plus se recentrer sur la fonction première du réseau social, c'est-à-dire les amis, nos proches, etc.
Je pense qu'ils n'ont pas persévéré dans cette voie-là, à ma connaissance.
On ne va pas parler de l'article 13 puisque c'est, voilà, ça, on...
Oui, parce que je connais déjà pas très bien le 11, je vais parler du 13.
Tu es journaliste, le journaliste start-up de La Libre Belgique ? Qu'est-ce qui fait justement... on en a, on a un petit peu touché à ce sujet tout à l'heure.
Qu'est-ce qui fait que tu apprécies cette culture start-up en Belgique ?
Je pense que c'est lié d'abord à ma manière de... depuis que je suis journaliste, donc depuis 92, je suis toujours resté grosso modo dans le domaine économique.
Mais c'est vrai qu'après quelques années, j'aime bien aller à la découverte de nouveaux secteurs ou de nouveaux domaines de l'économie.
Et c'est pour ça que j'ai été amené à évoluer, à travailler dans différents domaines. Et c'est vrai, y a trois ans, je me suis dit sur quel sujet je vais travailler.
Ce sujet-là m'est apparu intéressant et, mais vraiment le goût de la curiosité. J'y allais sans a priori, sans véritables connaissances.
J'y allais vraiment un peu dans la peau de celui qui... presque du Tintin reporter qui va dire : « Tiens, on parle beaucoup de start-up.
Le mot commence à... »
C'est quoi une start-up, finalement ?
Oui, voilà. Et donc je partais vraiment de zéro, même si j'y ai retrouvé forcément des éléments de management d'entreprise, de stratégie, de business plan, etc., que tu retrouves dans l'économie ou dans les entreprises plus classiques.
Mais c'est vrai que j'ai été au contact de ce domaine-là, de ce secteur émergent et que j'y ai croisé des gens que je n'avais pas eu la chance ou l'habitude de croiser auparavant.
C'est-à-dire des... J'avais... ça a cassé quand même certains stéréotypes, notamment par rapport à la jeune génération que l'on disait peu entreprenante, que l'on disait surtout soucieuse de s'assurer
un job dès la sortie de ses études et de préférence dans une banque ou dans une société d'assurance.
J'y ai trouvé aussi des gens... voilà, 'fin, j'ai... en fait, j'ai rencontré une génération, c'est un peu pompeux de le dire, mais que moi, j'aurais aimé faire partie de cette génération il y a 25 ans d'ici.
Finalement, tu as...
Je me suis un peu identifié à ça, même si je pense que j'ai pas du tout l'âme d'un entrepreneur.
J'ai envie de mettre ça en lien avec le fait que, j'ai écrit un papier là-dessus, le fait qu'en Belgique, de manière générale, il y a assez peu de création d'entreprise.
On est assez fort dans la sécurité, on a un patrimoine individuel très élevé, on aime bien garder l'argent en banque, on n'aime pas trop le risquer, pas trop...
voilà, peur de l'échec, peur du risque, etc. Et finalement, avec cette nouvelle génération, la génération Z/Y, tu as finalement trouvé un certain renouveau que tu ne trouvais pas en Belgique de manière générale.
Dans la morosité, surtout wallonne, un peu bruxelloise. Je découvrais des... notamment à travers le One Hour Challenge où chaque mois, on accueillait des start-up.
J'ai été heureux de découvrir qu'il y avait aussi un renouveau, un regain de,
dans le domaine de l'entrepreneuriat et en particulier dans la start-up, où finalement, on a là des outils qui permettent effectivement à tout un chacun d'innover et de...
Et puis le côté disruptif aussi des business qui étaient, que je voyais passer, le côté très positif aussi de gens qui,
qui avaient une relation à l'échec, même si on sait que c'est un gros problème en Belgique, mais qui avaient fait une, deux, trois tentatives, qui avaient déjà une ou deux, trois failles derrière eux, mais qui recommençaient autre chose.
Des profils intéressants.
Voilà, je trouvais ça plutôt, ça... on sortait vraiment du ronron classique...
conventionnel
...voilà, et je me suis dit : « Tiens, il y a quand même aussi ça en Belgique », même si je n'ai aucune idée de ce que ça représente.
Probablement qu'aujourd'hui encore, c'est...
Très minoritaire
...concentré sur un certain type de profils dans certaines régions, on le sait, hein, Bruxelles, Louvain-la-Neuve, Liège
Ouais, ouais, c'est exactement ça. La répartition des start-up en Wallonie, c'est surtout le Brabant wallon, donc plutôt pour les Français qui nous écoutent, c'est près de Bruxelles
...et c'est une bonne chose. Et puis voilà, j'ai rencontré des gens qui me plaisaient.
Tu parlais d'une certaine positivité dans ce portrait qui est dressé. Donc, tu rencontres des start-up, comme tu disais, dans le One Hour Challenge.
Il y a beaucoup de bullshit aussi quand tu écoutes les start-up. Est-ce que c'est facile de faire la part des choses et de...
Alors pas au début. Et je pense que certains ont dû un peu rigoler ou sourire en disant : « Tiens, La Libre découvre les start-up.
Ils font One Hour Challenge, comme tout le monde est beau, tout le monde est gentil. On fait Solvay, on fait LSM ».
Et finalement, pour caricaturer un peu, c'est tous les petits deux de Boitsfort et de Uccle et de Ixelles qui découvrent l'entrepreneuriat et qui, même s'ils se plantent, iront chez papa après.
Et je pense qu'il y a eu de ma part une certaine naïveté au début, parce que je découvrais et que j'avais un regard presque naïf et bienveillant sur tout ce nouvel univers qui s'ouvrait à moi.
Mais je n'ai pas voulu... dans un premier temps, mon job, c'était de comprendre. Comprendre qui sont les acteurs de l'écosystème, qu'est-ce qu'ils font, avant de me dire : « C'est bullshit... »
Et aujourd'hui, quand tu...
Aujourd'hui, je pense que j'ai acquis, après trois ans, un début de maturité qui me permet, et je pense que j'ai peut-être plus de légitimité aujourd'hui qu'il y a un an, certainement, pour dire : « Ça, c'est bullshit ».
Pour dire soit on l'a déjà fait, j'ai déjà entendu 10 fois.
Donc quand tu vois arriver, comme tu disais, un petit deux de Ixelles dans le One Hour Challenge, tu le traites différemment le sujet ?
Non, non, ça, honnêtement, moi, je passe au-dessus de ça aussi. Non, non. Ça, franchement, c'est pas un critère de sélection
Ah, c'est sélectivité, il y a un instant.
Oui, mais parce que j'observe que c'est comme ça.
D'accord, oui.
J'observe effectivement que, dans ces générations...
Le milieu entrepreneurial belge est encore assez typé, oui.
Voilà, mais ça, c'est un peu dans les gènes de la Belgique, hein. L'économie belge, l'économie de papa, l'économie des grandes familles.
C'est pas un hasard si effectivement aujourd'hui, la génération de nouveaux entrepreneurs émane notamment. Alors, Guillaume Hachez est un...
C'est moi
...est un contre-exemple. Heureusement, et tout ce que peuvent faire d'autres,
que ce soit dans des incubateurs, dans des
écoles de codage où heureusement, on va chercher aussi et on essaie de stimuler l'entrepreneuriat chez des gens qui n'ont pas la chance de naître avec une cuillère en or dans la bouche ou en argent, en argent,
et qui n'ont pas la chance de faire tous des études,
même si je pense que pour être un bon entrepreneur, il faut pas forcément faire de grandes études.
Et donc voilà, je pense qu'il y a une mixité qui va devoir être quand même ou une diversité qui n'est pas encore là...
Mhm
...et qu'il va falloir, j'espère, qui va grandir. Et donc aujourd'hui, mon regard a déjà un peu évolué. C'est pas par rapport aux petits deux.
C'est vrai que je citais l'exemple, mais c'est pas ça qui me... aujourd'hui, ce sur quoi j'ai un regard critique, c'est par rapport d'abord au côté très marketing aussi de gens capables de vendre leur boîte. Et que je tombe...
y a trois ans, je tombais facilement dans le panneau, je dis : « Ah oui, c'est génial », etc. Sans me rendre compte qu'en fait telle application avait été déjà faite 10 fois et que le mec, il n'avait juste qu'essayé,
qu'essayé de la transposer en Belgique.
Donc là, j'ai quand même un regard un peu plus aiguisé, heureusement, parce que j'apprends. J'apprends aussi, par exemple, par rapport au fonctionnement de l'écosystème hein.
On voit resurgir ou on a vu surgir finalement des dérives typiquement belges, voire wallonnes, dans la gestion, la manière dont on accompagne les startups, dans la manière dont on attribue les budgets publics, etc.
Donc là-dessus, j'essaie aussi d'avoir un regard plus critique,
mais dans le secteur privé aussi. Je vois aussi l'opportunisme de grandes boîtes privées par rapport au phénomène des startups qui disent : « Ah oui, là, allez, on va mettre...
on va plus dire starter, mais on va dire startup ».
Les grandes banques, notamment. Et voilà, elles essayent un peu de se mettre dans la tendance du moment.
Je vois aussi l'envers du décor des startupers. C'est-à-dire, je vois aussi que c'est pas... et là, c'est plutôt en faveur des gens qui se lancent là-dedans, c'est que
sur les quelques-uns qui réussissent et dont on parle dans les journaux, bon, y en a, y en a, y en a...
Beaucoup qui se plantent
...y en a beaucoup...
C'est normal, c'est normal
...qui rament, qui se lancent, qui échouent. Et j'aimerais bien de plus en plus m'intéresser à eux parce que je suis pas sûr que le regard de la société belge sur ceux qui échouent a vraiment changé.
C'est sûr. Mais justement, je voulais...
Ça, c'est...
...te relancer là-dessus. C'est les startups en Belgique, avec la question du regard de la société belge, la question du fonctionnement, de l'argent du papa, l'argent de la famille...
Oui
...etc. Enfin, tu le sais...
...parce qu'on en a déjà discuté. Je suis assez sévère, assez cynique...
Oui
...sur la scène startup en Belgique...
...et sur la situation. Bah l'exemple le plus concret, c'est le taux de création d'entreprises qui est très très faible en Belgique.
Et pourtant, quand on va écouter les acteurs publics, quand on va écouter le gouvernement fédéral, le gouvernement wallon, pour parler de ces questions, mais tout va super bien.
Les startups, ça décolle, on en crée plein, tout le monde en fait, et pas seulement un certain public du gouvernement wallon.
Voilà. Est-ce que... comment se fait-il qu'on soit aussi déconnecté ? Bon, alors, c'est complètement subjectif hein, mais comment se fait-il qu'il y ait une telle déconnexion entre les chiffres et la façon dont on...
Oui, oui
...dépeint la situation ?
Oui, c'est vrai qu'on... c'est souvent frappant quand on va à l'étranger aussi, dans des pays qui ont déjà un historique beaucoup plus long en termes de dynamisme entrepreneurial.
On a eu l'occasion de se rencontrer aux États-Unis. C'est vrai que c'est un peu,
c'est un peu la caricature, mais c'est vrai que quand tu vas à San Francisco ou à New York, bon ben, ou à Boston, tu sens effectivement que, comme ils disent là-bas, le mindset, ça fait un peu snob de le dire, mais...
C'est exactement ça.
C'est ça. C'est un autre mindset. Et là, je me dis : « Putain, on est quand même loin encore. On est encore...
On est très très loin
...encore dans la préhistoire. Et comment effectivement, un gouvernement, qu'il soit fédéral, wallon, vient nous dire : la Belgique ou la Wallonie devient un nouvel Eldorado.
Voilà, parfois, je dois un peu me pincer parce que...
Ils ont généralement tendance à se focaliser sur le fait qu'on a plutôt de bons chiffres en termes de croissance.
Oui.
Mais ils oublient de dire qu'il y a très peu de gens qui se lancent.
Oui, et honnêtement, pour l'instant, moi je suis convaincu que les choses évoluent et qu'elles bougent.
C'est sûr.
La génération Z, comme tu le disais.
Sur les cinq dernières années, je pense qu'on a fait beaucoup de choses et que ça va vraiment dans le bon sens. Maintenant, c'est le tout début de l'histoire.
C'est sûr. On part de loin, on part de loin.
Et pour relever ce taux de création d'entreprises et surtout connaître des réussites, voilà, on n'est pas encore arrivé.
Moi, je serais incapable de citer cinq startups wallonnes qui ont vraiment réussi, qui sont devenues des scale-up.
D'abord, c'est difficile de définir une scale-up, mais on parle d'Odoo. Bon, Odoo est une très belle réussite.
Mmm-hmm.
Mais derrière Odoo... Alors, je mets les biotechs de côté, je parle vraiment des startups numériques.
Quelles sont aujourd'hui vraiment celles qui vont être capables de créer 200, 300 emplois en étant au départ de projets de startup...
En partant de rien, oui.
...en partant pratiquement de rien.
Alors, toutes les startups ne doivent pas devenir des gros employeurs, mais vraiment des choses qui sortent, qui deviennent vraiment des références
au niveau... Comme en Flandre, ils ont déjà une avance quand même plus marquée.
C'est sûr, oui.
Ils ont de très belles réussites. En Wallonie, on manque encore de réussites.
Oui.
Mais voilà, ça va venir. Et je suis sûr que le fait aussi aujourd'hui que de plus en plus d'entrepreneurs commencent à redonner ce qu'ils ont peut-être eu et gagné ou eu comme expérience, de réinvestir dans des boîtes.
Tout ça est assez lent, mais ça va plutôt dans le bon sens. Et donc, c'est une drôle d'alchimie tout ça, entre le public, le privé, l'entrepreneur, la bonne équipe, etc.
On parle souvent de la culture de l'exemple et de l'importance des role models. Est-ce que tu as le sentiment que--
est-ce qu'en fait, c'était un de vos paramètres, un de vos objectifs en créant le-- enfin, en affichant le One Hour Challenge dans La Libre Belgique ?
Parce que de participer à ce mouvement-là de-
Oui, clairement. Et ça, je l'assume et je le revendique. C'est-à-dire, je pense que
il était intéressant et de notre rôle de donner une visibilité médiatique à tout un pan de l'économie qui n'avait pas suffisamment de-- qui n'était pas suffisamment représenté dans la presse francophone belge.
Ça veut pas dire qu'on était les premiers à le faire, certainement pas. Il y avait d'autres journalistes avant moi qui se sont intéressés avant moi à ce sujet-là.
Mais c'est vrai qu'il y avait un tel déséquilibre entre l'importance qu'on peut donner aux grosses boîtes, celles du Bel20,
pour parler des boîtes belges, et tout ce tissu d'innovation, d'entrepreneuriat,
que voilà, à travers le One Hour Challenge, on a voulu vraiment montrer à nos lecteurs que, ben voilà, il y avait aussi une nouvelle économie qui était en train d'émerger.
Et le fait de l'avoir fait avec LeanSquare, pour moi, ça m'a permis aussi d'accélérer ma-
Ta transition.
...ma transition et ma connaissance du secteur, parce que je suis tombé sur des gens comme Ben Picker ou Roald Sibbersen qui sont, eux, dans le milieu et l'écosystème depuis longtemps,
et qui ont pu me mettre, alors eux, en contact avec d'autres.
Maintenant, voilà, heureusement, j'ai élargi mes horizons grâce à ça, mais le One Hour Challenge, on va pas le faire non plus pendant dix ans.
Donc il faudra passer à autre chose. Mais pour l'instant, en tout cas, vu qu'il y a un intérêt des start-up de faire savoir ce qu'elles font et...
Maintenant, ce qui va être intéressant de faire, c'est un suivi surtout, parce que moi, ce qui m'intéresse comme journaliste, c'est aussi de-
Oui, de parler de ceux qui-
...de parler de ceux qui s'accrochent et qui vont, comme Quiteric, qui vont grandir et tous les autres.
Et donc ça, c'est le plus intéressant. Ou aller voir ceux qui se sont plantés, pourquoi ? Qu'est-ce qui a manqué ?
Voilà. Parce que je commence maintenant à rencontrer aussi, à connaître des boîtes, voilà, qui malheureusement n'ont pas tenu un an ou deux ans et...
Mais globalement, tu es optimiste et tu penses qu'on va dans le bon sens et que les choses vont en s'améliorant.
Oui. Maintenant, parfois, je me demande si je vis pas trop dans-- On reproche souvent aux journalistes de vivre un peu-
Dans sa bulle.
...oui, dans sa bulle. Et parfois, j'aimerais bien qu'on me dise : « Attends, tu te fais des-- » pas des illusions, mais parfois peut-être que, voilà, il faudrait pas que je reste trop dans une bulle Bruxelles, Béwé, Liège.
Il faudrait que je voie aussi, voilà, que-
Tu veux chercher des entrepreneurs dans les Ardennes, c'est ça que tu dis ?
Mais que je reste vigilant sur le, voilà, pour éviter de tomber dans ce que tu appelais le bullshit quoi. Et parce qu'il y en a qui sont très doués pour faire du marketing entrepreneurial.
Et donc voilà, ça, c'est mon rôle de journaliste. Et c'est pas les entrepreneurs qui vont me le dire, mais de déguiser mon regard pour être sûr d'identifier vraiment les gens qui,
qui innovent et qui ont les-- parce que tout le monde peut pas être entrepreneur.
Moi, je veux pas être dans une société où on dit : il faut être entrepreneur. Voilà, s'il y en a plus, tant mieux, mais je suis convaincu que tout le monde ne peut pas l'être et que voilà-
Non, c'est sûr.
...Et, mais s'il y a des gens dans la nouvelle génération qui ont ça dans leur ADN, waouh ! Moi, je suis vraiment admiratif parce que moi, je serais incapable d'être entrepreneur.
Moi, je saurais pas être entrepreneur. J'ai de l'admiration en fait pour-- parce que j'ai de l'admiration pour les gens qui ont des trucs que moi, je n'ai pas.
Et je suis pas du tout technicien, je suis pas un leader, mais voilà, je suis curieux et j'aime voir des gens qui...
C'est peut-être aussi parce que mon fils arrive à un âge où il pourrait devenir un startuppeur et je me dis : « Tiens,
c'est quand même super que dans notre société à nous, ici en Belgique, c'est une chance d'avoir tous ces gens-là.
Il faut les aider, mais il faut pas non plus les glorifier à tout prix, je dis ça vous... » Mais voilà, moi, c'est une catégorie de gens dans l'économie qui m'intéresse plus que de m'intéresser à des,
voilà, des grands capitaines d'industrie avec des moyens importants, etc. Voilà.
OK.
Tout ce qui sort, toute la matière grise qui sort de cette nouvelle génération m'intéresse. C'est voir un peu ce qu'elle est capable de faire.
Donc, une note positive alors pour ce côté. C'était très intéressant. Merci beaucoup Pierre-François.
Merci à toi Guillaume.
Et on se retrouve pour un prochain épisode très bientôt. Au revoir.
Au revoir.
Et c'est déjà tout pour cet épisode. Je remercie Pierre-François de m'avoir accordé une heure de son temps. C'était très intéressant.
On a rapidement émis quelques critiques vis-à-vis de la scène start-up belge. Pour ceux que ça intéresse, j'ai écrit un article à ce sujet il y a à peu près un an.
Ça parle de la peur du risque, de la peur de l'échec qu'on connaît ici en Belgique et de pourquoi on n'a pas assez d'entrepreneurs.
Ça s'appelle Des Hobbits en Belgique et c'est disponible sur Medium. Si vous avez apprécié cet épisode, n'oubliez pas de vous abonner sur votre plateforme de podcast préférée.
Et si vous écoutez sur iTunes, essayez de me laisser cinq étoiles, ça m'aide énormément. Allez, à très bientôt.